the supreme court which was held up as a
major
major major shot at uh overturning the
election
thanks to a bombshell lawsuit for donald
trump
has completely anticlimactically
rejected the case
and this has made donald trump and many
of his supporters absolutely lose their
minds now as a reminder this was a
lawsuit we discussed last week on the
bonus show
it was a lawsuit by texas backed by
donald trump
suing to throw out or block
the voting results from four different
states
now the idea was texas sued
claiming georgia michigan pennsylvania
and wisconsin
were fraudulent or as trump says
fraudulent
and should be prevented from certifying
the results
which officially happens today december
14th and may already have started by the
time
you listen to today's show or watch the
the this clip
the idea was get this to the supreme
court
and then donald trump's three supreme
court picks
will defiantly and heroically support
the lawsuit
and stop today's electoral vote
certification now the supreme court said
no
justices said texas doesn't have
standing to bring the case we'll talk
more about what standing means
um a little bit later but this entire
bombshell lawsuit that they've been
claiming
is going to just interfere and overturn
the results
it's gone in an instant with the supreme
court decision
the president absolutely lost it check
this out donald trump tweeting
that the supreme court chickened out
saying quote the fact that the supreme
court wouldn't find standing in an
original jurisdiction matter between
multiple states
and including the president of the
united states is absurd
it is enumerated in the constitution
they just
chickened out and didn't want to rule on
the merits of the case
so bad for our country now of course
what's bad for the country
is a president who clearly lost
unwilling to concede
unwilling to say he will go to the
inauguration unwilling to admit that his
voter fraud claims are not based in fact
that's bad for the country
trump then wildly tweeting in all caps
this went on for hours really even days
most corrupt election in u.s history
trump continuing to go at the supreme
court saying that quote the supreme
court had
zero interest in the merits of the
greatest voter fraud
ever perpetrated on the united states of
america all they were interested in is
quote standing which makes it very
difficult for the president to present a
case on the merits
75 million votes now of course trump got
75 million but joe biden got way more
and won the electoral college trump's
white house press secretary
and senior campaign advisor she's both
kaylee mcinanny
appeared on fox news with sean hannity
moments after the decision on friday
and said the supreme court dodged
yeah there's no way to say it other than
they dodged
they dodged they hid behind procedure
and they refused to use their authority
to enforce the constitution
so look at how quickly number one
friends become enemies for trumpists
this is typical
of narcissists it's very very typical
you're the friend
and he's built the greatest supreme
court with his three picks and thank god
trump got to pick him instead of hillary
except
now the supreme court is chicken and the
supreme court dodged so
very quickly friends become enemies when
the paradigm is narcissism uh
weaponized narcissism and number two
look at how quickly the goal posts are
moved
first it was we will overturn states
with recounts
recounts didn't work and then they said
well right the recounts recounted
fraudulent ballots so of course the
recounts are fraudulent as well
we need to throw out ballots couldn't
present any evidence every court said no
so next it went to prevent certification
by states
but state certified so it was sue to
block
december 14th certification go to the
supreme court
supreme court said no now i'm there were
more intermediate steps i'm giving you
the highlights
they're irrelevant they'd always find
more steps
more reasons to say donate money to us
to fight this or to fight that there
really is no end to it the reality is
if you thought it hadn't already ended
weeks ago
we now are at the end and at the end of
the show i'll tell you about today's
electoral votes officially being cast
they won't be counted in congress until
the first week of january
presided over by mike pence that'll be a
day but we'll talk a little bit later
about what's going on today
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely
free service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plug-in
let you give each company a randomized
virtual credit card number that you
create out of thin air it'll even
autofill the card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set spending limits you
can freeze them
you can delete them anytime you want so
when you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be because you
can destroy
the virtual card number right after
using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over
if i use a virtual credit card number
you're keeping your identity private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or credit
card info protected against data
breaches and identity theft
and it's free there's no catch
whatsoever but if you want
privacy also offers a ten dollar a month
plan that gives you one percent cash
back and lets you create
36 credit cards a month and a 25
a month plan tailored more for small
businesses where you can create
60 card numbers a month and much more
but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info
companies can't charge you unexpectedly
and like i said
you'll get five dollars to spend when
you sign up
at privacy.com slash pacman